six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the
five six two area code five six - who's
this my name is Jonathan I'm actually
calling from Long Beach okay go ahead
Jonathan so I had a question in regards
to the citizenship question on the
census I'm not too sure of that question
already asked earlier what do you when
in your opinion what do you think Trump
wants to accomplish with that question
and what would be some of the
ramifications yes so the idea is if you
put a citizenship question on the census
even if that information cannot be used
to find and deport undocumented
immigrants and of course there's
disagreement about that it's still going
to scare a lot of people in the United
States away from even completing the
census if the people who are scared away
from competing completing the census are
not just undocumented immigrants but
also legal immigrants who maybe just
don't want to draw more attention to
themselves because they understand the
political climate that's going on you
are going to have minority groups
underrepresented in the census because
the census is used for redistricting and
allocation of funds you are going to
have big blue states with a lot of
immigrants receive less proportionately
in funding and you're also going to see
possibly depending on exactly how it all
comes out you could see red states with
a smaller immigrant population end up
with more representation in the House of
Representatives than blue state so it
the impact could be absolutely huge okay
perfectly if it's just one simple
question whether you're you you are a US
citizen or not wouldn't it just be
easier for people just to say yes or
citizens since there's no way to
necessarily verify that oh you mean just
lie on the question even if the answer
is no yeah correct sure there you're not
wrong that individuals could certainly
do that but the problem is that what
you're trying to do with a policy like
this in a country of 320 million people
is you're trying to affect very very
large numbers so if only a percentage of
individuals do
participate because of the presence of
that question you can still achieve your
political objectives by doing it by
including the question okay
Oh perfect well thank you - Thank You
France my question David all right now
we really appreciate it
wonder if it's a criminal offence to lie
on the census for it probably is yes I I
mean I don't know exactly but there's
certainly a lot of other cases that
could be made it's it's not quite an
interesting question but it's certainly
not quite that simple there's other
reasons people wouldn't just do that